ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU GEN. TO CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN APRIL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA IN. WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK MERCK SILVA
RAMOS AREAS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
JEAN MELENDEZ VIA FOOD WELL.
WELL WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DAZE PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YES SIR KHAN
IMAM YASIR. AND THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. REVEAL
THE BLESSINGS OF DIVERSITY AND
THE MANY AND A MANY SHAPES AND
FORMS THAT IT HAS BECOME
MANIFEST IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
IN OUR WORLD. MAY WE ALWAYS SEE
OUR DIFFERENCES AS A SOURCE OF
STRENGTH. MAY IT ALWAYS BE USED
TO UNITE. AND NOT TO DIVIDE I
MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER CALDERON. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JANUARY THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS IN THE
MINUTE SEVENTY ON THE ABA BRIAN
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SERVICE OF THIS PRESIDING TWO
CLERKS YOU PARK AT THE DESK
REFLECTIVE ON THE READING THE
FOLLOWING ARE PLACED UPON THE
MORNING ROLL CALL I RECORD
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BEEN IT
BERMAN BLOOMBERG OR ABOUT BONTA
BURKE MIDDLE RAMOS MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESIDENT AND PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. MARCH OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
WILLING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORETTA
GONZALEZ. IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TIM GRAYSON FOR MEDICAL LEAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL QUIRK IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FRANK BIGELOW.
WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FOR FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
DOLLING LOW MCCARTY GALLAGHER
BLOWN. FRIEDMAN AND BURKE TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS. MEMBERS
A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT THIS PAST
SATURDAY WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US HIS BIRTHDAY. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY LOOSE. ADD TO MORROW
IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHIL TING
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING THEM BOTH. A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS AND
RETAIN. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. H. R. FIFTEEN.
AND THE CLERK THREE HOUSE WAS
LUCIEN FIFTEEN BY SIMPLY MEMBER
THREE OF US RELATIVE TO
AMERICAN WOCKHARDT MONTH AND
WEAR RED DAY MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MS RIVAS
MYSTERY OF US. YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
HR FIFTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZES
WEAR RED DAY AND FEBRUARY AS
AMERICAN HEART MONTH. I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU WHO WORE RED
TODAY IN RECOGNITION OF OUR
ANNUAL CAPITAL GOES RED EVENT.
H. FIFTEEN RAISES AWARENESS OF
THE PREVAILING RATES OF HEART
DISEASE IN WOMEN TO EMPOWER
WOMEN TO TAKE CHARGE OF THEIR
HEALTH. AND REDUCE THE RISK OF
HEART DISEASE. HERE ARE A FEW
STARTLING FACTS HEART DISEASE
CLAIMS A WOMAN'S LIFE EVERY
EIGHTY SECONDS. CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
MATERNAL DEATH AMONG WOMEN IN
THE UNITED STATES ACCOUNTING
FOR MORE THAN ONE IN THREE
PREGNANCY RELATED DEATHS. BLACK
LATINA ASIAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN ARE AT A
HIGHER RISK OF DEATH FROM HEART
DISEASE STROKE AND OTHER
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES YET
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO KNOW
THE RISK. OVER THE PAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS GO RED FOR
WOMEN HAS FUNDED LIFESAVING
WOMEN'S RESEARCH ADVANCE PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY AND CREATED A
PLATFORM FOR WOMEN TO ADDRESS
THEIR GREATEST HEALTH RISK.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE. HR
FIFTEEN FORMALLY RECOGNIZES GO
RED FOR WOMEN AND AMERICAN
HEART MONTH TO RAISE AWARENESS
WOMEN. BY INCREASING AWARENESS
AND EMPOWERING OTHERS TO REDUCE
THE RISK FOR CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASES WE CAN SAVE THOUSANDS
OF LIVES EACH YEAR AND BE A
RELENTLESS FORCE FOR A
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
AND I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THE
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS. SEEING
THEIR- OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE ITEM. MS
RIVAS IS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE THE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CHARACTERS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR.
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
OF THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WHERE THE
GERMANSIN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS MEMBERS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THROUGH MY TEARS WRITING THIS I
STRUGGLE TO FIND THE RIGHT
WORDS. A BIG AN UPWARD.
SOMETHING PROFOUND ENOUGH.
BLACK ENOUGH TO TRULY DESCRIBER.
NO WORDS COULD EVER DO OUR
JUSTICE SHE WAS AND WILL ALWAYS
JUST BEING CICELY TYSON. AN
ICON AND A LEGEND SHE WAS THE
TRUE EMBODIMENT OF THE DIGNITY
AND THE MAGIC OF BLACK WOMEN.
SHE WAS BORN IN NEW YORK CITY
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR TO
IMMIGRANT PARENTS AND QUICKLY
LEARN THE MEANING OF HARD WORK
SELLING HANDBAGS IN HARLEM. AND
ONLY NINE YEARS OLD. AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL SHE WORKED AS A
SECRETARY FOR THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS. BUT WHAT MOST PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE IS THAT MISS
TYSON AS SO MANY NEW HER
STARTED HER ENTERTAINMENT
CAREER AS A MODEL STARTING AT
AGE THIRTY. WHEN MOST MODELS
WITH AND THEIR CAREERS AT THAT
STAGE HERS WAS ONLY BEGINNING.
ONLY PROVING SHE LIVED BY HER
OWN RULES AND NEVER CONFORMED
TO ANY BOUNDARIES. NOT ONLY A
MODEL MISS TYSON ALSO FOUND
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS ON THE
SCREEN AND ON STAGE WHERE SHE
WAS KNOWN TO HAVE. ONLY
ACCEPTED ROLES THAT HAD REAL
SUBSTANCE. IN HER MEMOIR MISS
TYSON WROTE. I WAS DETERMINED
TO DO ALL IT COULD TO ALTER THE
NARRATIVE OF CLOUT BLACK
PEOPLE. TO CHANGE THE WAY BLACK
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR ARE
PERCEIVED BY REFLECTING OUR
DIGNITY. WITH THIS INSPIRING
AND POWERFUL MINDSET SHE
ACHIEVED A SUCCESSFUL CAREER
THAT SPANNED DECADES. SOME OF
HER MOST CELEBRATED ROLES
INCLUDE THOSE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE MOVIE'S GOT
FOUNDER FOR WHICH SHE WAS OSCAR
NOMINATED THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR TELEVISION FILM THE
AUTOBIOGRAPHY OF MISS JANE
PITTMAN FOR WHICH SHE WON TWO
EMMYS. AND THE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN BROADWAY REVIVAL OF A
TRIP TO BOUNTIFUL FOR WHICH SHE
WON A TONY AWARD FOR BEST
ACTRESS AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT. HER CAREER WAS NOT ONLY
RECOGNIZED AND CELEBRATED BY
THOSE IN THE PERFORMING ARTS.
BUT BY EVERYONE. AND HER
BROTHER BRILLIANCE WAS FORMALLY
RECOGNIZED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. WHEN SHE WAS AWARDED
THE HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR. THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
BY PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA. MISS
TEXAS CAREER AND LIFETIME
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AMERICAN
CULTURE. OR NOTHING SHORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY. SHE INSPIRED THE
SOUL AND CHALLENGE THE MIND.
SHE NCOURAGE COMPLETE
AUTHENTICITY NOT JUST IN OUR
PERFORMANCES BUT IN LIFE. SHE
BELIEVE THE GREAT INSPIRATIONS
CAME FROM LIVING FROM YOUR SOUL
AND SHE EMBODIED THAT. IN EVERY
THING SHE DID AND IN THE MOST
SIMPLE INTERACTION. SHE WAS A
CREATIVE GENIUS SHE WAS KIND
WARM AND LOVING SOUL. SHE GAVE
ME HOPE THAT ANYTHING'S
POSSIBLE. AND BECAUSE OF THAT I
TRUSTED HER WITH MY DEEPEST
DREAMS AND MY GREATEST FEAR.
SHE WAS MY PARENTS CHERISHED
FRIEND FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS.
SHE WAS MY GODMOTHER AND SHE
WAS A CONSTANT SOURCE OF
INSPIRATION I'M UP. AND I WILL
MISS HER SO MUCH. WEBER WITH
THANKSGIVING GROWING UP WITH
HER AND MY ALSO MY WEDDING MY
SWEARING INTO THE ASSEMBLY OR
HOURS ON THE PHONE SHE WAS
ALWAYS THERE. BUT WHAT I WILL
MISS THE MOST IS OUR TIME
TOGETHER. TALKING IN A QUIET
CORNER IN THE BACK OF HER LOCAL
NEW YORK DAILY. A GDMOTHER IS
A SPECIAL ROLE RESERVE FOR
THOSE WILL THE MOST YEAR. AND
SHE WAS. LIKE IN EVERYTHING SO
SHE DID A REMARKABLE. ONE I
pSHE WILL DO THAT WE COULDN'T
STOP FOR FUTURE I. I ALSO PRAY
THAT SHE REST IN PEACE. AFTER
INSPIRING GENERATIONS THROUGH
NINETY SIX YEARS. SHE HAS
EARNED IT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADDRESS THE
MEMORY BUT MISSED THIS WEEK
TYPE THING. THANK YOU MISS
BURKE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY TO IN
TURN THE MEMORY OF A
TRAILBLAZER WHO WAS A FIXTURE
HERE IN OUR SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY. LORI MAKE BRIDE WAS
A RENOWNED LOBBYIST AND
ADVOCATE FOR HER COMMUNITY AS A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE. LORI WAS
BORN IN LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN
FORTY NINE INVENTOR OF NORTH.
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC TO
PURSUE HER COLLEGE CAREER IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. SHE
SERVED AS SECRETARY FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. AND THEN BECAME
PRESIDENT OF THE SAME MORNING
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING FROM
EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHTY SIX. FROM
THERE. LAURIE ENTER THE WORLD
OF POLITICS STARTING FROM THE
GRASSROOTS LEVEL AND WORKING
HER WAY UP TO THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF LEADERSHIP THE
MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS. ONE OF
OUR MOST SUCCESSFUL POSICIONES
BURKE FOR WITH THE HIV AND AIDS
AWARENESS AND ANTI
DISCRIMINATION POLICIES. SHE
THEN JUMPED. SHE MADE THE JUMP
TO THE CAPITAL AND SERVED AS
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE DENTIST
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER KEVIN SHELLEY
SHELLEY. FROM TWO THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO SHE THEN
SERVED AS ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OF STATE WHEN SHELLEY WAS
ELECTED TO SECRETARY OF STATE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE.
LAURIE AND HER WIFE WERE
RESIDENTS IN THE GALLEY A
CALIFORNIA WHICH I AM PROUD TO
REPRESENT. AND LAURIE WILL BE
SOLD SOLD THE MIST AND BOTH HER
COMMUNITIES OF SACRAMENTO IN
THE GALLEY AT. JUST RIVER
SURVIVED BY HER WIFE DONNA
ALONG WITH MANY FRIENDS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO CHERISH
HER MEMORY. LORI WAS INCREDIBLY
ACCOMPLISHED ADVOCATE WHOSE
COMMITMENT TO VALUES OF
EQUALITY AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL INSPIRED HER TO ACHIEVE
GREAT THINGS. MEMBERS I ASK YOU
JOIN ME IN THE MEMORY OF LAURIE
MCBRIDE. THANK YOU MISTER L. A.
MR LOW YOU WERE ALSO RECOGNIZED
ON THIS GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I ALSO JOINED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBTQ
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO GIVE OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHIES ON THE
PASSING. OF OUR NICK BRIDE.
ASSEMBLY WE EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES TO ROY'S WIFE DONNA.
HELLO MY PRIDE WAS OUT. HE WAS
OUT OF THE CLOSET IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHAT IT WAS
DANGEROUS TO BE OUT. DANGEROUS
TO BE OUT. AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
GLORY THAT INDIVIDUALS LIKE
MYSELF AND SO MANY OTHERS CAN
STAND BEFORE YOU AND EQUALLY BE
OUT. I OUT AND PROUD. PASSION
AND AGASSI LATE SAVE THE LIVES
I'LL SAY THIS AGAIN BECAUSE IT
BEARS REPEATING WELL I MAKE
BRIDE SAVED LIVES THERE IS NO.
NOBLER PURSUITS LAURIE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS AN INSPIRATION
FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT THEMSELVES
TO CREATING TRUE EQUALITY FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO COME.
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR LOW MR MCCARTY YOU
ARE ALSO RECOGNIZED IN THIS
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LAURIE
MAKE BRIDE AND REMEMBER HER
TREMENDOUS LIFE. SHE WAS A
MEMBER AND RESIDENT OF MY
DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
LIVED IN LAND PARK FOR MANY
YEARS LATER IN LIFE HE MOVED TO
THE NORTH STATE LIVED IN THE-
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND-
SHE WAS A PIONEER AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CUPERTINO
MENTIONED. BUT SHE WAS ALSO MY
FRIEND HERE LOCALLY AND MANY
PEOPLE IN THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY KNEW HER. AS A MISTER
LOWE NOTED SHE WAS OUT AND
PROUD BEFORE IT WAS POPULAR SHE
WORKED IN THE TRENCHES ON THESE
ISSUES WHEN THERE WAS A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
DOING CELL. SHE HAD A DIFFERENT
CAREER IN THE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES. AND THEN AFTER HER
CAREER SINCE HE SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO GO IN THE INSIDE
I WANT TO MAKE CHANGE. FROM THE
INSIDE. SO SHE WENT AND WORKED
FOR OUR THEN SPEAKER AND-
ANTONIO VILLARAIGOSA. BECAME
HIS LEAD STAFF MEMBER AND
ADVOCATE ON LGBT ISSUES. BEFORE
THERE WAS- MARRIAGE EQUALITY
BEFORE THERE ARE MANY OF THESE
ISSUES. IT WAS VERY HARD WHEN
THESE BILLS CAME OUT THAT SHE
WAS WORKING ON. THERE IS
FIFTEEN TWENTY THIRTY VOTE
SOMETIMES YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THE
MOVIE RECENTLY THE DOCUMENTARY
POLITICAL ANIMALS. THAT WAS HER
WORK BEHIND THE SCENES OF
MAKING SOME OF THESE LAWS. A
REALITY. SHE WAS ALSO VERY
ACTIVE HERE LOCALLY WITH OUR
STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB. A
LEADER IN THAT ORGANIZATION. AS
STATES WOMAN IN THE COMMUNITY
AND MENTOR TO MANY OTHER. YOUNG
LEADERS LIKE OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM- CUPERTINO WHO ARE YOU
LOOKING TO RUN FOR OFFICE. SHE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I STILL
REMEMBER HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
HER HER WORK HER LEGACY LIVES
ON. WITH THAT I ASKED WE DURING
HER MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY. MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ANTI WALL. A BELOVED
COACH PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
TWELFTH AFTER AN ONGOING BATTLE
WITH CANCER AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
FORTY FIVE. WHAT WAS A SOCIAL
BUT WAS A SCHOOL TEACHER AT
CHICO JUNIOR HIGH FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. HE HAD A PASSION
FOR COACHING SOFTBALL AND IS
REMEMBERED AS A GREAT COACH AND
EVEN BETTER FATHER AND FRIEND.
GOING UP IN YUCAIPA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND HE MARRIED HIS
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART SHEILA
AND THEY MOVED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HE GOT HIS FIRST
TEACHING JOB AT PARADISE HIGH
SCHOOL. AND THEN MOVED TO CHICO
JUNIOR HIGH IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. INDIAN SHEILA REYES THREE
AMAZING CHILDREN TANNER
SAVANNAH AND SADIE. HE IS
REMEMBERED BY HIS WIFE AS A
RENAISSANCE MAN. AND HUNT CAMP
AND FISH WITH THE FAMILY DURING
THE SUMMER. SOME OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL AND IMPACTFUL
TITLES ANYONE CAN HOLD IS ONE
OF COACH. MENANTI LOVE TO
COACH. AND HE LOVED. WORKING
WITH ARE YOU. IN GETTING THEM
TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL AND
PUSHING THEM IN. AND SEEING
THEM SUCCEED. ANY COACH YOU
SOCCER T. BALL BASEBALL SOME
BASKETBALL BUT SOFTBALL WAS HIS
TRUE PASSION. WELL WAS BROUGHT
ON AS THE COACH OF THE CHICO
HIGH SOFTBALL TEAM IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WHICH ACTUALLY
COINCIDED WITH HIS DIAGNOSIS OF
CANCER. DESPITE A SERIES OF
MAJOR SURGERIES WALL STAYED ON
AS COACH THROUGH IT ALL
WATCHING THE GAMES REMOTELY
WHEN HE COULD BE THERE. AND WAS
UNDERGOING TREATMENT. AND
THROUGH ALL OF THAT GOING
THROUGH CANCER AND THE AND THE
TRIALS OF THAT DISEASE- THE
PANTHERS. AT CHICO HIGH WON
THREE STRAIGHT NORTHERN SECTION
CHAMPIONSHIPS FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND THE
WALL WAS NAMED TEACHER OF THE
YEAR. THIS WAS TRULY AN AMAZING
MAN. IN MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
THE TEAM DEDICATED THE FIELD TO
THEIR COACH WITH A PLAQUE
COMMEMORATING ANTI WALL AS
QUOTE THE STRONGEST MAN WE KNOW.
WHAT A TESTAMENT TO A COACH. TO
A FATHER. A FRIEND TODAY I ASK
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF ANTI WALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER. MISTER
BLOOM YOUR RECOGNITION- IN THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR A GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
LARRY KING WHO WAS ONE OF THE
MOST PROLIFIC INTERVIEWERS AND
WELL KNOWN TALK SHOW HOST OF
OUR TIME. KING WAS A RESIDENT
OF BEVERLY HILLS WHERE HE WOULD
FREQUENTLY HOLD COURT IN A
CORNER BOOTH IT NAY NOW'S
DELICATESSEN. HE WAS BORN
LAWRENCE HARVEY ZEIGER ON
NOVEMBER NINETEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY THREE IN BROOKLYN NEW
YORK. TO HIS PARENTS WHO HAD
EMIGRATED FROM LITHUANIA AND
UKRAINE. HIS CAREER IN MEDIA
TOOK OFF IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHEN HE BEGAN WORKING AS
A DISC JOCKEY AT W. H. W. A. H.
R. A. M. IN MIAMI. IT WAS THEN
THE KING DECIDED TO CHANGE HIS
LAST NAME FROM ZEIGER TO KING
AT THE SUGGESTION OF AS GENERAL
MANAGER. THAT DECISION WAS MADE
ABOUT A HALF AN HOUR BEFORE HE
WENT ON THE AIR FOR THE FIRST
TIME. WHAT FOLLOWED WAS AN
INCOMPARABLE CAREER IN MEDIA
AND JOURNALISM. THAT SPANNED
OVER SIXTY YEARS AND INCLUDED
PRINT. RADIO AND OF COURSE
TELEVISION. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE LARRY KING LIVE FIRST
AIRED ON CNN. OVER THE COURSE
OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS KING
CONDUCTED OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
INTERVIEWS AND TAPED OVER SIX
THOUSAND EPISODES INTERVIEWING
EVERY SITTING PRESIDENT FROM
GERALD FORD TO BARACK OBAMA THE
DALAI LAMA NUMEROUS ATHLETES
AND CELEBRITIES. AND EVEN
KERMIT THE FROG AND MISS PIGGY.
LARRY'S INTERVIEW STYLE WAS
MORE CASUAL THAN MANY OF HIS
COUNTERPARTS KING SAT ACROSS
FROM HIS GUESTS DONNING HIS
ICONIC ROLLED UP SLEEVES A PAIR
OF SUSPENDERS AND OVERSIZED
GLASSES YOU CAN PICTURE THIS
RIGHT AND ASKING A FEW
QUESTIONS. OF WHOMEVER HE WAS
INTERVIEWING AND THEN LEANING
IN TO LISTEN INTENTLY TO THEIR
ANSWERS. AND AS HE FREQUENTLY
REMARKED HIS PHILOSOPHY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL LEARN
FROM VERY SIMPLE. USED TO SAY
I'VE NEVER LEARNED ANYTHING
WHILE I WAS TALKING. KING
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
SEVEN AND IS SURVIVED BY A SON
LARRY JUNIOR CHANCE AND CANNON
AN ASSET WE ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL AND GERMAN IN MEMORY
THANK YOU AGAIN AND MEMBERS
TODAY I ALSO RISE TO RETURN IN
THE PRIMARY. OF ONE OF THE
GREAT RABBIS OF LOS ANGELES
RABBI ALAN FREELING WHO IS THE
SENIOR RABBI AT THE UNIVERSITY
SYNAGOGUE IN LOS ANGELES. RABBI
FREELING WAS BORN IN CHICAGO
AND RAISED IN MIAMI WHERE HE
GRADUATED FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF MIAMI. IN ROLLED IN HEBREW
UNION COLLEGE AT THE AGE OF
THIRTY AND BEGAN AS RABBINICAL
SERVICE AT A CONGREGATION IN
TOLEDO OHIO BEFORE MOVING TO
LOS ANGELES TO ASSUMEASSUME
THE POSITION OF SENIOR RABBI AT
UNIVERSITY SYNAGOGUE. RABBI
FREELING GROOVY UNIVERSITY
SYNAGOGUE CONGREGATION FROM
AROUND TWO HUNDRED FAMILIES TO
MORE THAN A THOUSAND. HE WAS A
TIRELESS HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST AND COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
HE DEDICATED HIMSELF TO HELPING
THE GROWING HOMELESS
POPULATIONS IN LOS ANGELES AND
ADVOCATED FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. AND WAS AN EARLY
ADVOCATE FOR INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH HIV AIDS DURING THE HIV
PANDEMIC. DUE TO HIS ADVOCACY
RABBI FREELING WAS APPOINTED AS
THE FIRST YEAR OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COMMISSION ON AIDS AND
LATER BECAME THE FOUNDING CHAIR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF PROVIDERS OF
AIDS CARE. RABBI FREELING
RETIRED FROM THE UNIVERSITY
SYNAGOGUE IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
BUT AS TIRELESS ADVOCACY DIDN'T
END THERE HE WAS APPOINTED BY
THE MAYOR JAMES K. HAHN TO
SERVE AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HUMAN RELATIONS COMMISSION.
FOLLOWING HIS SERVICE THERE HE
SERVED AS DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR NOW CONGRESSMAN TONY
CARDENAS. RABBI FREELING PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY SIXTH AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY EIGHT AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LAURIE. IS
CHILDREN SHARE AND JONATHAN AND
THEIR SPOUSES HIS SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND FOUR GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
PRODUCT REALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. MS FRIEDMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMLING. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY TURN OF THE MEMORY OF
MR LOS ANGELES MY FRIEND
COUNCIL MEMBER TOM A BUNCH. TOM
THE BOND WAS BORN IN LOS
ANGELES AND GREW UP IN SILVER
LAKE HE GRADUATED FROM MARSHALL
HIGH SCHOOL AND CAL STATE LA.
HIS DEDICATION TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE IN THE CITY THAT HE
LOVED STARTED EARLY. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR HE SERVED
ON MAYOR TOM BRADLEY AS YOU
COUNSEL. TWO YEARS LATER HE
BEGAN HIS CAREER AS A STAFF
MEMBER FOR THE LA CITY COUNCIL.
FIRST WITH COUNCIL MEMBER PEGGY
STEVENSON FOLLOWED BY A FIFTEEN
YEAR STINT WITH COUNCIL MEMBER
JOHN FERRARO. OF COURSE MOST OF
US KNOW HIM FROM HIS OWN TIME
ON THE COUNCIL FROM
200-012-2000 FIFTEEN. TOM
REPRESENTS THE FOURTH DISTRICT.
REGARDED BY HIS PEERS AS A
FORCE OF NATURE HE WAS ALSO.
THE CITY'S BIGGEST CHEERLEADER.
AND I'LL TELL YOU FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS SO OFTEN IN THE
SPOTLIGHT AS TOM THE BOND WAS.
HE ALWAYS UNFAILINGLY USE THAT
SPOTLIGHT. TO SHINE ON OTHER
PEOPLE AROUND HIM. HE WAS NEVER
ALONE ON THE STAGE. TOM THE
BOND WOULD ALWAYS BE SO EXCITED
TO HAVE A MINUTE TO INTRODUCE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ALL UP ON
STAGE WITH HIM. NEVER TALK
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS DOING WOULD
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT WHAT EVERYONE
ELSE IS DOING. AMBER WHEN I WAS
FIRST ELECTED TO THE GLENDALE
CITY COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. OTHER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN LOS ANGELES REALLY
DIDN'T HAVE MUCH INTEREST IN.
COUNCILMEMBERS IN THE SMALL
CITIES AROUND THEM YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU WERE IN LA THAT WAS
THEIR TOWN. BUT TOM THE BONTA
NEVER HE WOULD SEE ME IN
GRIFFITH PARK OR ANYWHERE ELSE
WOULD SHOUT OUT. THERE IS
COUNCIL MEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN
AND HE WOULD PULL ME UP ON THAT
STAGE WITH HIM LIKE I WAS THE
MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES. AND I
LEARN THIS GREAT LESSON FROM
HIM ABOUT HUMILITY AND ABOUT
SHARING THAT SPOTLIGHT. AND
ABOUT SUPPORTING OTHER PEOPLE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I CARRIED
TO THIS DAY AND I WOULD AT
WHENEVER I SAW TOM THE BOND.
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE I COULDN'T
HELP BUT SMILE THAT'S WHO HE
WAS HE WAS SINGLE SOMEONE WHO
BROUGHT JOY. HE WAS ALSO THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES'S BIGGEST
CHEERLEADER. AND THIS WAS
SOMEONE WHO KNEW EVERY LANDMARK
THE HISTORY OF HIS CITY. LIKE
HE KNEW HIMSELF. HE WOULD
ALWAYS TELL YOU SOME LONG
STORY. ABOUT A TREE OR A
BUILDING OR AN ARTIFACT AND IT
WAS SOMETHING HE REALLY REALLY
REALLY ENJOYED. NOW ONE OF HIS
MOST SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS
WAS HEADED HIS EXPANSION OF
GRIFFITH PARK BY FIVE HUNDRED
ACRES. HIS LOVE FOR THE PARK
NEW NO BOUNTY WAS ALL OVER THAT
PARK EVERY DAY. WITH DAILY
HIKES LEADING PEOPLE AROUND- HE
KNEW ALL THE TRAILS AND IN
FACT. AFTER HE RETIRED I WENT
ON A HIKE WITH BEN ALLEN'S
MOTHER CONSTITUENTS AND THERE
WAS TOM A BUNCH. AND IN FACT
EVERYWHERE WE GO TOM THE BOND
WOULD SHOW UP IT WAS SORT OF A
JOKE WITH OUR STAFF WITH WORST
TIME THE BUNCH- THERE HE IS.
AND IT WASN'T THAT HE WAS
STALKING ME. IT WAS THAT HE
LOVED HIS CITY SO MUCH THAT HE
COULDN'T STAY HOME. HE WAS
ALWAYS ALL OVER THE FOURTH
DISTRICT PICKING UP TRASH.
DELIVERING MUFFINS. TALKING TO
PEOPLE SHOWING ANYONE WHO WOULD
LISTEN ABOUT THE CITY HE WOULD
JUST STAND THERE AND- YOU WERE
THERE YOU WOULD SAY HEY COME ON
OVER HERE LET ME SHOW YOU THIS
LET ME SHOW YOU THAT. WELL TWO
WEEKS AGO HE WAS HONORED BY THE
MOUNT HOLLYWOOD SUMMIT IN
GRIFFITH PARK WHICH HAS
INCREDIBLE VIEWS- WAS RENAMED
BY THE CITY TOM A BUNCH SUMMIT.
AND I KNOW THAT TIME IS LOOKING
DOWN FROM HEAVEN AND SMILING AT
THAT AT TO BE THAT PART OF
HISTORY AND HAVING THAT
MEMORIALIZED. TOM IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE OF FORTY ONE YEARS
BRIDGET. HIS DAUGHTER MARY KATE
LABONTE AND SON CHARLES THE
BOND. BOTH OF LOS ANGELES. AS
WELL AS BY HIS BROTHERS BRIAN
LABONTE GLENDALE. DENIS LAVANT
OF NEWPORT BEACH ROBERT THE
BUNCH OF MALIBU. TIMOTHY
LABARGE OF DESERT HOT SPRINGS
AND MARK THE POINT OF LOS
ANGELES. HE WAS SOMEONE WHO IS
UNSTOPPABLE HE HAD A HEART OF
GOLD HE REALLY WAS AND STILL IS
MISTER LOS ANGELES AND- BELIEVE
ME I WILL MISS HIM DEARLY. BUT
NEVER NEVER FORGET HIM THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAME TO THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. ALL
REQUESTED A JURY MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY FEBRUARY NINTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
FEBRUARY TENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY FEBRUARY ELEVENTH
CHECK IN SESSION. FRIDAY
FEBRUARY TWELFTH FOUR SESSIONS
AT NINE AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THE BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MS REYES MOVES MISS WALDRON
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY FEBRUARY
TWELFTH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.